hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday
between world champion Magnus Carlsen
and 14-year old international master
from Denmark Yanis bull BIA and it's a
wonderful game first Magnus calls and
held the simultaneous exhibition where
he faced 24 opponents and he defeated
all 24 with a perfect result would have
perfect results 24 to 0 and then he had
a short exhibition match to rapid games
against this young gentleman here so
this is one of the games that we are
going to show maybe I will show on the
other one as well so far I haven't
decided but before we check out this
very nice game I do have two very short
announcements first one is that well
we've we've well not we actually a
friend of mine with a developer for
Android created this argument of chess
clock and he said that he decided to
take it up as well as a side project
where he could you know create something
that he enjoys so he created it as you
can see it's available on Google Play
Store still unreleased as this is only a
beta now so if any of you are interested
in you know testing it out it's it's
completely free it has no ads it's a
very light very quick so it you know he
he tried to make it as the best chess
clock available on Android so if you're
interested in testing it out you know
giving us a few pointers maybe maybe it
doesn't work as it should on your device
maybe this maybe that you know who knows
that's why apps are tested before they
are fully released so the first thing
you will see in the description below is
a link to the Google Play Store for for
the Android app for this agamotto chess
clock and also a huge congratulations
and thanks to even scottish for
achieving this in in very short record
time i think he completed it in under a
month and he also had some other very
important business to do what that means
said that's one part of the announcement
so I do hope some of you will be
interested in helping us out with
testing of this app now if you do you
know I do hope you enjoy it and also
Magnus Carson is coming to Scotland so
if you are by initials from Scotland and
you if you are somewhere near the little
indoors abbey distillery where they make
whiskey you can follow this Chester's
tournament it will be for now
the health people that are confirmed our
world champion magnus carlsen as you can
see former world champion vishwanathan
anand and three times chinese chess
champion ding leer and neither you know
now they need any introduction but you
know that chess side makes one
nevertheless and since Sergey Huracan
was knocked out of the feeder Grand Prix
I heard rumors that he might also be
joining them here at this well whiskey
distillery so if you are somewhere you
know in the vicinity of that maybe you
can even check it out in person and you
know send me some nice photos but that
being said as we will be covering that
short tournament you know we still
haven't covered the tournament played in
a whiskey distillery and you know might
be nice if they were like maybe they
have to have a shot of whiskey every
five moves or something like that you
know just to make it more interesting
but I think I think we already discussed
that but we're gonna return to that in a
few days as it starts in two days so
that being said I will also put a link
in the description below with a chest 24
a link to the website where you can
check out all the games from the
simultaneous exhibition and both of
these games as well plus the the live
stream from the simultaneous exhibition
if you're interested in that but that
being said let's check out the game
without further ado so yonas opens it
with the white pieces he plays efore we
have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to b5 going for the rule opus
with a 6 more fees defense the shop
today for g6 now do you think ghetto
variation we have castles of Iona's and
Bishop to g7 we have C 3 and here d6 by
Carlsen vishwanatham Anand had this
position against the domani
in last year's Isle of Man tournament
where he played b5 and Anand was able to
win that game but cross and chooses a
different line we have d6 d4 now Bishop
to d7 and now rook to e1 by white knight
to G to e7
and here comes d5 and here there are a
few games in the database where Knight
to a5 was played four games to be exact
and white won all four games so not a
move obviously you want to play tonight
b8 by Carson we have the subchapter son
d7 Knight captures and E's
and now comes see for just strengthening
that bond here with h6 by Carson taking
away this g5 square from the night also
if you know by any chance h4 h5 comes g5
will be ready
we have Knight to c3 Yanis continuous
development and now calls and finally
castles we've looked to be one preparing
to further expand on the Queen side and
now comes f5 Carson is ready to attack
on the King side and you know a nice
flank attack is the same in the center
with b4 by white and now comes Knight to
f6 by Carlsen and here there is one game
in the database where a4 was played
between Andre Pengo and Anton de
mishchenko in 2016 were black won the
game but here a for isn't played we have
nice the d2 and it is as of this moment
on more 15 that we have a completely new
game
so it's yonas who deviates from from any
known line we have c6 by Carson
challenging white strong center and now
brush up the b2 we've roped the c8 a
nice move the roof as this C file is
about to be open very soon Queen to b3
and now just see capture Sundy 5c
captors and e5 and now b5 white of
course doesn't want to have a backward
spawn either so we have a 4 and now
comes Queen to b6 by Carson and here you
have to decide what to do now a 5 seems
like a very nice idea but after Queen B
7 you don't really have a good way of
taking advantage of any of the squares
that your pawns hold yeah I mean there's
it's very hard to imagine that any of
your Knights will be able to get any of
these squares since all of these squares
here are covered you can't really use
them so here instead of pushing with a
captures on b5 bionis a capture some b5
and now just rook to e1 SDA file is now
also an open file on the board Yanis
decides to grab hold of it maybe with
ideas of rock a5 may be followed by
other broken stay 1 and then trying to
do something with that but first we have
F captures on e4 and it's very
interesting there's a there is an old
thing interest to take is a mistake if
you don't gain anything by taking
something then just don't take it so
obviously Carson has something in mind
by playing F captures on e4 what's the
idea
yeah well the idea is next we have night
capture Sun d4 Knight captures on d4
Knight sorry on e4 Knight captures on e4
and now rook the c-4 this is Magnus idea
it's a really a multi-purpose move the
rook now blocks the Queens defense
towards the d5 pawn so Knight captures
here is a threat also there's pressure
against the knight on e4 the knight is
the only defender of the f2 pawn
well the King defends it as well but
that's of little help as the rook and
queen are eyeing that after pawn so the
real threat is just capturing the knight
and the Queen captures on f2 so you do
have to prevent it best way of defending
this position is king to h1 and now of
course if Carson is about to grab the
pawn then you can just play Knights to
d2 and this rope has nowhere to move
where the rook can protect the Knight d4
is covered by the Bishop c5 is covered
by the pawn so here you would have to
play Queen c7 and well now you will be
able to capture the knight but it
doesn't really do all that much for
white as Carlsen will have full
compensation 3-connected passed pawns in
the center of the board or a
compensation enough for the exchange
after remove the Queen just Knight to f4
and now you can just start pushing the
pawns it will be very dangerous but it
was the best course of action for white
here a white place Queen to g3 with the
idea okay now if course and captures I'm
just gonna capture this pawn threaten to
capture this guy here Knight f4 Queen
captures this is the game wife is trying
to play but Carlson says no thank you I
have a different idea and it's a it's
really a nice idea as for example the
engine on depth 23 doesn't see this move
but after we play this move so if you
had a headed set I to to a deeper depth
then the engine sees the move so it's
not all that easy to find but I will ask
you to pause the video here and try to
find the winning move for Carlsen in
this position I'll give you I'll give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you were an excellent lifter of the
second rook as well and for the Duke who
just won enjoy the show
crossings idea was rook to f4 and now
you can see that there's so many
attacks going towards this night here
it's not all that easy to defend it and
if you move it
for example it's a night to be to just
attacking the rook then you play route
capture some before and now that this
pawn is eliminated it's just going to be
very hard to play this brush up see
Tahrir okay for let's say you trade here
and now you have this very very strong
passed pawn you're going to eliminate
the d5 pawn as well we're gonna start
pushing your pawns and it's just gonna
be an overwhelming position white will
not be able to hold
so here Yanis had tried a different idea
he played Queen to d3 but we already
said why this is a bad idea but just for
me to check if you were listening feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the correct winning idea for Magnus here
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you were paying
attention I'll give you that and for
those of you who just won enjoyed show
we removed the defender of the f2 pawn
so that's the idea with rook captures
Knight rook see captures on e4 and we
have rook captures on e4 so the f2 point
is no longer guarded and now comes Queen
captures an f2 with check King to h1
okay now there's no checkmate because
the both the Queen and the rook are
guarding the f1 square but you can just
grab the bishop that is undefended on b2
so Queen captures and b2 and now we have
rook captures on f4 you have to play
something we have it captures on f4
although here before even capturing the
bishop you know I guess if capablanca
was playing this position he would first
capture the rook here just because you
know there's a less or less to calculate
you know makes makes sense now but
Coulson doesn't mind he plays Queen
captures in he just says okay you do
whatever you want with your rook I don't
really care
we have rook captures on f4 and now
there's really nothing to gain if you do
this in between move Queen captures
anyone with check rope or can just block
so you don't gain any more material so
here we have e captures on f4 now comes
Luke to e1 getting drunk out of harm's
way
Knight to f5 not allowing any nice rock
lifts well you could deliver this check
but there's no follow up after King - h7
Queen captures some b5 yonas still
fighting created a path beep on he wants
to start pushing it up the board we have
nice day III now
checks with the rock are no longer
possible Queen check doesn't really do
anything either as now you also have to
defend checkmate on g2 so Queen to d2
defending checkmate and also hoping to
trade Queens and start pushing this past
pawn but now just wink after some b5 and
before cross and doesn't allow any
counter play we have looked to see one
and now comes the Queen to e4 again
constantly keeping pressure here you
could deliver this check like I said
after King h7 now you have to defend
against any back rank made threats and
also you have to defend against this
made threat I might even use this a
thumbnail who knows Luke will have to go
back and really didn't achieve anything
you've only improved the position of the
black king so Queen to f3 hoping to
trade but now cousin doesn't mind Queen
captures we have G captures and now
Bishop to e5 just solidifying in the
center
now the knight will eliminate this pawn
and the well it's just completely
winning Knight and Bishop against the
rook a being up two points sorry one
pawn but soon to be two pawns here we
have looked to see it check King to f7
and it was in this position after moved
35 into a 7 that fourteen-year-old
International Master from Denmark unis
bobbya resigned the game he resigned
because we already mentioned why there's
no point in continuing after you do one
more check like say you can go King to
f6 and now there's no defending the pawn
whatever you play just Knight captures
now black is up 2 points and of course
bishop in the night against rook is
completely winning so he doesn't he's
not interested in continuing this game
yeah a very nice game by world champion
Magnus Carlsen and you know definitely
it was a nice game bye-bye yonas as well
but you know it's hard to well it wasn't
easy to spot that rook the four move
really especially since the engine also
doesn't see it at least on undef 23 as
we already mentioned so once again if
you're interested do give us a hand with
evaluating the Argonaut of chess clock
you know any any tip is more than
welcome you can comment on google play
in there are comments available below so
you can do that or you can send an email
to to even and then he will implement
any changes
well you recommend if they are necessary
and also like I said if you are from
Scotland do check out the chest Arts
Tournament in Linz Dora endorse a be a
distillery so that's basically it
I do hope you enjoyed the game I would
like to thank hardmode cackler and
Alexander Wilson for a contribution to
my channel thank you what I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
most likely continuing the Fida Grand
Prix 2019 but also checking up on your
suggestions as usual I think I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day